por aquí tengo la fórmula molecular de
la glucosa así que vamos a decir que
tenemos una muestra de glucosa pura por
aquí
esta es la glucosa y no nos dicen su
masa pero con base en su fórmula
molecular podemos encontrar el
porcentaje de la masa del carbono de la
muestra pausa el vídeo y piénsalo y como
pista nos dan la masa atómica promedio
del carbono del hidrógeno y del oxígeno
muy bien vamos a trabajar juntos la
razón del por qué no importa la cantidad
de glucosa es que el porcentaje de la
masa del carbono debe de ser el mismo
sin importar la cantidad para ayudarnos
a pensar esto podemos imaginar una
cierta cantidad de glucosa supongamos
que tenemos un molde glucosa entonces
ahora podemos pensar que si tenemos un
molde glucosa tenemos 6 moldes de
carbono porque cada molécula de glucosa
tiene 6 átomos de carbono y con esto en
mente podemos preguntarnos cuál será la
masa de 6 moles de carbono dividido
entre la masa de un molde glucosa
una vez más la razón del por qué tenemos
seis moldes de carbono es que si
suponemos que este es un molde de
glucosa y cada molécula de glucosa tiene
seis átomos de carbono
entonces habrá seis moles de carbono por
cada molde glucosa ahora cuánto será
esto bueno esto será igual a en nuestro
numerador tendremos seis moles de
carbono por la masa molecular del
carbono cual es la masa molecular del
carbono bueno podemos obtener la de la
masa atómica promedio del carbono si la
masa atómica promedio es de 12.01
unidades de masa atómica unificadas
entonces tenemos
12.01 gramos por mol de carbono entonces
esto por 12.01 gramos formol de carbono
y podemos observar que en el numerador
nos quedaremos sólo con gramos como
unidades
y ahora en el denominador que tendremos
bueno necesitamos la masa de un molde
glucosa ahora cada molécula de glucosa
se forma con 6 átomos de carbono 12 de
hidrógeno y 6 de oxígeno entonces
necesitaremos la masa de 6 moles de
carbono 12 moles de hidrógeno y 6 moles
de oxígeno
ahora vamos a dividir lo que tenemos
aquí entre 6 moles de carbono por la
masa molar del carbono que es 12.01
gramos por mol de carbono ya esto le
sumaremos 12 moles de hidrógeno por la
masa molar del hidrógeno que es 1.008
gramos por mol de hidrógeno más 6 moles
de oxígeno por la masa molar del oxígeno
que es 16.00 gramos por mol de oxígeno y
la buena noticia es que los moles de los
elementos se cancelan así que nos
quedaremos con gramos como unidad del
denominador y esto tiene mucho sentido
ya que nos quedaremos con gramos en el
numerador y con gramos en el denominador
por lo que se cancelarán y obtendremos
sólo un porcentaje al final y veamos en
el numerador tenemos 6 por 12.01
es 72 puntos 0 6 mientras que en el
denominador bueno primero hagamos los
cálculos y después nos preocupamos por
las cifras significativas en el
denominador tendremos 72 puntos 0 6 + 12
por 1.008 es 12.0 96 y después tenemos 6
por 16 lo cual es 96.000 y esto será
igual a 72 puntos 0 6 entre 72 más 12 es
84 96 es 180 0.06 más 0.0 96 es lo mismo
que 0.156 lo hice bien sólo sumamos todo
esto sin preocuparnos por las cifras
significativas ahora podemos escribir
esto en la calculadora pero debemos
recordar que nuestra respuesta
debes de tener más de cuatro cifras
significativas incluso acá abajo en esta
operación azul sólo deberíamos tener
cuatro cifras significativas así que
tenemos que obtener una respuesta hasta
el lugar de los centésimos incluso en la
suma si redondeamos con el fin de tener
cifras significativas tendríamos al
menos cuatro de hecho tendríamos cinco
cifras significativas así que cuatro
serán nuestro factor limitante de cifras
significativas por lo tanto calculamos
esto y vamos a redondear a cuatro cifras
significativas 72.0 6 entre 180.169
firmas
y si redondeamos a cuatro cifras
significativas tendremos punto 4000 así
que vamos a decir que esto es igual a
punto 4000 o podemos decir que tenemos
un 40 por ciento de la masa del carbono
en nuestra muestra cuando redondeamos a
cuatro cifras significativas y ya está
hemos acabado